CH: Hasta que punto es lo que pasó,
en parte, solo una consecuencia no deseada,
que el medio tradicional en el que trabajaste
tenía un rol curativo-mediador,
donde ciertas normas fueron observadas,
ciertas historias serían rechazadas porque no eran creíbles,
pero ahora que el estándar para la publicación y la amplificación
es solo interés, atención. emoción, hacer clic.
"¿Le hicieron clic?"
"Envíenlo"
y eso eso pasó. ¿Es parte de lo que causó el problema?
CA: Creo que hay un gran problema y lo vimos en la elección de 2016,
donde la idea de"clickbait" era muy sexy y atractiva
y así todos esos sitios de noticias falsas y artículos de noticias falsas
no eran publicados al azar y por coincidencia.
Existe toda una industria en la creación de noticias falsas
en partes de Europa del Este, donde sea,
y esté plantada en el espacio real y en el ciberespacio.
Y creo también
que la habilidad de nuestra tecnología para hacer proliferar estas cosas
a la velocidad del sonido o de la luz a tal punto
nunca la habíamos enfrentado jamás.
Y no habíamos enfrentado una cantidad enorme de información
que no estuviera revisada
por aquellos cuyas profesión los lleva a aceptar la verdad
a chequear hechos
y a mantener un código de conducta y un código de ética profesional.
CH: Muchas personas aquí deben conocer gente que trabaja en Facebook,
Twitter, Google y demás.
Todos parecen personas geniales con buenas intenciones.
Vamos a asumir eso.
Si pudieses hablar con los lideres de esas compañías,
¿qué les dirías?
CA: Bueno,
estoy segura de que tienen muy buenas intenciones
y que ciertamente desarrollaron un sistema innovador increíble,
donde todos están conectados en esta cosa llamada Facebook.
Y han creado una economía masiva para ellos
y tienen unas ganancias increíbles.
Yo diría,
"Chicos, saben, es tiempo de despertar y oler el café
y mirar que es lo que está pasándonos ahora.
Mark Zuckerberg quiere crear una comunidad global.
Yo quiero saber: ¿Cómo será la comunidad global?
Quiero saber donde están los códigos de conducta.
Mark Zuckerberg dijo,
y no lo culpo, probablemente lo creía
que es un locura pensar
que los rusos o quien sea estuvieran manipulando
por esta vía.
¿Y que aprendimos en las últimas semanas?
Esto, en realidad, ha sido un problema grave en ese aspecto
y ahora tenemos que investigarlo y descubrirlo.
Sí, están intentando hacer lo que pueden ahora
para prevenir el aumento de las noticias falsas
pero, ya sabes,
fue bastante ilimitada por un largo periodo de tiempo.
Entonces supongo que les diría
Uds. son brillantes en tecnología;
descifremos otro algoritmo.
¿Se puede?
CH: Un algoritmo que incluya una investigación periodística
CA: No sé cómo se debe hacer, pero de alguna forma
¡filtren la mierda!
(Risas)
Y no solo lo involuntario,
(Aplausos)
sino también las mentiras deliberadas plantadas
por personas que lo hacen
desde hace décadas.
Los soviéticos, los rusos
son los amos de la guerra con otras tácticas de conflicto híbrido.
Y esto es
lo que decidieron hacer.
Funcionó en EE. UU.
no funcionó en Francia,
no ha funcionado en Alemania.
Durante las elecciones allá donde intentaron interferir,
el presidente de Francia ahora Emmanuel Macron,
tomo una posición muy fuerte y lo confrontó
igual que Angela Merkel.
CH: ¿Hay algo de esperanza de tener algo así?
Que el mundo aprenda.
No engañaron una vez,
tal vez nos engañaron de nuevo,
pero tal vez no la tercera.
¿Es la verdad?
CA: Supongo, esperemos.
Pero creo esto también es sobre la tecnología,
que la tecnología se le tiene que otorgar una especie de brújula moral.
Sé que estoy diciendo tonterías, pero ya sabes a lo que me refiero
CH :Necesitamos un algoritmo filtra-mierda con una brújula moral.
CA: Así es, eso es.
CH: Pienso que es bueno.
CA: No. "Tecnología moral".
Todos tenemos brújulas morales, tecnología moral.
CH: Creo que es un gran desafío. CA: Sabes a lo que me refiero.
CH: Hablemos ahora sobre liderazgo.
Tuviste la oportunidad de hablar con muchas personas de todo el mundo.
Creo para algunos de nosotros,
hablo por mí, pues no sé, si todos se sienten así,
hay una especie de decepción:
¿Dónde están los líderes?
Muchos de Uds. están decepcionados.
Aung San Suu Kyi, lo que pasó recientemente,
es "¡No! Otro que muerde el polvo"
Te rompe el corazón.
(Risas)
¿A quién has conocido
que te ha impresionado, que te ha inspirado?
CA: Hablas del mundo en crisis,
lo que es absolutamente verdad,
y aquellos de nosotros que hemos pasado nuestras vidas inmersas en esta crisis,
quiero decir, que estamos todos al borde de un ataque nervioso.
Ahora mismo es muy estresante.
Y tienes razón,
hay un vacío perceptible actual en el liderazgo.
Y no es que yo lo diga, lo pregunto siempre,
a todos los que les hablo, les pregunto sobre liderazgo.
Hablaba con la extrovertida presidente de Liberia hoy,
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,
quien
(Aplausos)
en un periodo de tres semanas,
será una de las escasas líderes de un país africano
que acata la Constitución
y entrega el mandato una vez cumplido su periodo.
Ella ha dicho que lo que quiere hacer es dar una lección.
Pero cuando le pregunté sobre el liderazgo,
y mencioné fugazmente un grupo de ciertos nombres,
le mencioné el nombre del nuevo presidente francés,
Emmanuel Macron.
Y ella...
Yo pregunté, "¿Qué piensas cuando digo ese nombre?"
Y ella dijo,
"Está formándose potencialmente para ser
un líder que llene el actual vacío de liderazgo."
Pensé que era muy interesante.
Ayer tuve una entrevista con él.
Estoy orgullosa de decir,
que obtuve su primera entrevista internacional. Fue genial, fue ayer.
Y estaba muy impresionada.
No se si debería decirlo en un foro abierto,
pero estaba impresionada.
(Risas)
Y podría ser porque era su primera entrevista,
pero le hice preguntas, y ¿sabes que?
¡Él las respondió!
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
No hubo giros,
no hubo vueltas,
no hubo una espera de cinco minutos para volver al punto.
No tuve que seguir interrumpiendo,
algo por lo que soy conocida,
porque quiero que la gente responda a las preguntas.
Y él me respondió
y fue muy interesante
Y dijo--
CH: Cuéntame lo que dijo.
CA: No, no, te toca.
CH: Tú eres el que interrumpe, yo escucho
CA: No,no, te toca.
CH: ¿Qué te dijo?
CA: Has hablado sobre nacionalismo y tribalismo hoy.
Le pregunté, "¿Cómo tuviste el valor de confrontar las tendencias dominantes
de la antiglobalización, nacionalismo, populismo
cuando ves lo que ha pasado con Brexit,
cuando ves lo que pasó en EE. UU.
y lo que pudo haber pasado en muchas elecciones europeas
al comienzo de 2017?"
Y él dijo,
"Para mí el nacionalismo significa guerra.
Lo hemos visto antes,
lo hemos vivido en carne propia en mi continente
y soy muy claro al respecto".
Así que él no iba solo por lo políticamente conveniente,
asumió el mínimo común denominador
asumido en otras elecciones políticas.
Y él se enfrentó a Marine Le Pen, quien es una mujer muy peligrosa.
CH: Última pregunta,Christiane.
Cuéntenos ideas dignas de difundir
¿Si pudieses plantar una idea en las mentes de todos aquí
cual sería?
CA: Yo diría ten cuidado de donde obtienes la información,
asume responsabilidad por lo que lees, escuchas y miras.
Asegúrate de ir a los grupos fiables para obtener información,
no importa si tienes una amplio consumo ecléctico,
quédate con las marcas que conoces,
porque en este mundo ahora en este instante
nuestras crisis, nuestros desafíos, nuestros problemas son tan severos
que al menos que estemos todos conectados como ciudadanos globales
que aprecian la verdad,
que entienden la evidencia científica o empírica y los hechos,
estaremos divagando hacia
una potencial catástrofe.
Así que diría la verdad
y luego volvería a Emmanuel Macron
y hablaría sobre amor.
Yo diría que no hay suficiente amor.
Y le pregunté que me hablara sobre amor.
Le dije, "Su matrimonio es el tópico de una obsesión global"
(Risas)
"¿Puedes hablarme de amor?
¿Qué significa para Ud.?"
Nunca le pregunté a un presidente o líder elegido sobre el amor
Pensé que tendría que intentarlo.
y él dijo, realmente me respondió.
Y él dijo, "Amo a mi esposa ella es parte de mí,
estamos juntos hace décadas"
Pero esto es lo que me contó
que realmente me quedé.
Él dijó,
"Es muy importante para mí tener alguien en casa
que me diga la verdad".
Así que lo traje a mi hogar hablemos sobre la verdad.
(Risas)
CH: Así que ahí lo tienes. Verdad y amor. Ideas dignas de difundir.
Christiane Amanpour, muchas gracias. Fue un gusto.
(Aplausos)
CA: Gracias CH: Fue un placer.
CA: Gracias.